I don't know much about Lisa but a smart
old witch is a very jealous person and
she's trying to like fight off his
female fans and female fans are very
very useful so it's actually not good so
bro how's the music and everything is
fine
do you remember one song that seemed a
good deal for you anything man a good
yeah that song I sing for Lisa I can't
with word and you will see so I shoot
the video would mean more to you know
bring out the reality of the song song
yeah but Lisa she see the video she see
what you did isn't for me and now you
brought another lady to take all this
off for really you did like the video I
did not like it I took away from the
concept of the song so I dedicate the
video to take out the model all the
shots that that lady was in take you
know we are you serious Lisa you're
causing a lot of trouble with the
concept of the song there's I'm 7,000
miles away the song is about me and him
the model should not have been in the
video you really don't understand how it
works in the music industry are you
trying to say like in America it should
music video love songs without the model
in it ah yes
Makena love some the very good love some
shoots in a video without a model and
it's normal to put it it's like a tea
without sugar
did you talk
your listeners do be disappointed and to
be a successful artists and entertainer
you don't want to disappoint your
friends
I'll show you seriously you know I mean
I mean I mean I'm in the game show how
it works yeah yeah let me ask you a
question like are you trying to destroy
his music career
[Music]